so you and kendrick working together
there it is kendrick lamar
right you guys got a record on that l.a
russell and kendrick lamont
on the way
on the way come on you heard it here you
heard it here
it's funny too because i saw you post
the joe budden thing
and i thought that was so funny
right it was like
obviously he was talking about you right
did you have any did joe budden reach
out to you at all no he didn't he didn't
reach out i actually had a fan of mine
hit me and was like bro i think he's
talking about he's got to be talking
which is dope like yeah me like a lot of
moments i miss because i don't really be
watching like pop bra i'd be like
working like putting [ __ ] together
yeah so like they sent me and was like
he's definitely talking about you so
i've seen i'm like man that's dope you
feel me i love joe budden but just
showing the love that he did show in a
very joe budding way you feel me in a
very joe budding way a very joe burning
way you feel me but for i i know for him
that that took a lot you feel me so it's
like that [ __ ] cool and he's not giving
that co-sign to a lot of people you feel
me